it's never bothered me to play i'm just
a kid 20 years later or i'm sorry i
can't be perfect or
uh or welcome to my life
welcome to my life
yeah i still enjoy playing them and i i
just love seeing a massive crowd
reaction and if you play the songs that
they know of course they're going to
sing a lot more they're going to be
jumping up and down so i'm all about it
[Applause]
[Music]
the joy
that my heart felt
when i saw
you and derek whibley on ruin my life
yeah that was so cool you know we we're
both canadian bands that have had in a
lot of ways parallel careers we came out
about the same time they've had
incredible success in the same scene
that we have and it's just our way of
selfishly getting someone that we are
fans of to be part of our record so
derek i don't think that he hasn't done
a lot of collaboration so it was nice
for us to be able to be one of those
very few and you'll find that all
canadian collab on simpleplan's sixth
studio album harder than it looks
it's celebrating how lucky we are to be
where we are still today you know 20
plus years later still putting out
records still playing shows in front of
sold out audiences most things in life
it requires a lot of hard work so yeah
it's about being this fan it's about
being an adult it's about all those fun
things